[MUSIC]
>> I was hosting my first
dinner at Stanford.
Already an insecure hostess, this is
was a pretty stressful occasion for me.
I had managed spaghetti and
meatballs, which we'll call passable.
And I had purchased an obscene
quantity of cheap Trader Joe's wine
in an attempt to hide my poor cooking.
We were well into our third bottle
when one of my new friends, Jennifer,
turned and said can I ask you a question?
Sure, I said.
I hoped it wasn't going to be anything
about the cooking, because then I'd have
to admit that pretty much everything
in front of us had come out of a box.
Instead, she said Anna, you and
Jason have been married for two years.
What do you think is the secret to love?
My heart was racing as the room turned and
stared at me.
First, I definitely do not
believe that there is a secret.
And secondly, I also did not
believe that being married for
two years qualified me as any
sort of relationship expert.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I can't remember what I said, but
I can guarantee that at that time
it was neither true nor helpful.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It was one of those moments where I
really, really wished I had an answer.
I spent a lot of time
thinking about this question.
And thanks to a lot of you who
came to me to ask love advice,
you know who you are, Jackie.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm here in front of you one and
a half years later with what I
think is a true and helpful answer.
Love is a wave with highs and lows.
Some of our deepest lows are conflict.
And although our relationship might
appear perfect on the outside, Jason and
I are no different from most couples.
One of our deepest lows
happened five years ago.
My mom was diagnosed with breast cancer.
I was devastated.
I called Jason, and
he came home from work immediately.
He bought me a train ticket
from New York to Boston, and
he walked me to Penn Station
at four in the morning.
The next few months were challenging,
to say the least.
I commuted from Boston to New York,
trying to care for my mother and
also trying to do a good job at my
work as an investment banking analyst.
One weekend,
my mom seemed to be doing well, so
I decided that I was going to go home and
catch up on my work in New York.
Jason was on vacation across the country,
and
he decided to surprise
me by coming back early.
Of course, I totally agreed to
go to a short dinner somewhere
in the neighborhood.
30 minutes later,
we found ourselves still stuck in a cab.
Our cab driver had committed the 8th
cardinal sin known only to New Yorker's.
He had taken us through Times Square.
>> [LAUGH]
>> 45 minutes later we
finally arrived at a charming
cubbyhole in the West Village,
that charmingly,
kept its reservations on pen and paper.
And charmingly, had lost our reservation.
An hour and
a half later we were finally seated.
Two hours later we had obtained bread and
water with the promise of wine on the way.
Two and a half hours later was
when I completely lost it.
I got mad at Jason.
I yelled at him, and I accused him
of the most heinous of offenses,
trying to do something nice for me.
How dare he?
Despite my egregious behavior,
we were married in 2012, and
this is one of our wedding photos.
Although I remembered
talking through this issue,
I still wasn't sure why Jason forgave me.
So a few weeks ago,
I called him to ask him about this and
he said, at the time,
you had an aura of gloom around you.
Seriously, an aura of gloom?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yes, an aura of gloom.
I blame the context.
I didn't blame you.
We had had so many happy memories, and
I could see a path forward to
many more happy memories to come.
Love is a wave with highs and lows.
When I was researching love I came across
the work of Chipney, a psychologist who
studies how we behave in relationships,
particularly during conflict.
As it turns out, we all have these mental
models that deeply impact how we behave,
even though we don't realize.
The first is this concept of destiny,
the idea of meant to be.
We're all familiar with this concept,
the thought that there is one person
out there who we're meant of find.
I blame Hollywood and Disney.
The second is the idea of growth.
This is based on Carol Dweck's
work on mindset.
Carol says that people who have a growth
mindset tend to embrace failure.
They view it as an opportunity to learn.
People with a fixed mindset instead
view failure as a ding against their
intelligence and they stop trying.
It turns out that it's remarkably
similar in relationships.
People who are high on the growth spectrum
tend to view conflict as inevitable,
as something that needs
to be worked through.
And even as an opportunity to
become closer to your partner.
People who are low on
the spectrum give up very easily.
Destiny is much more complicated.
Early on,
it can completely kill a relationship.
After all, you wouldn't be having a petty
squabble with your loved one about where
to go for dinner on Friday night if
you were meant to be with them, right?
Later on, it's much more complicated.
On the one hand, it can make
you work harder to salvage this
relationship that you're meant to be in.
But it can also cause denial and
avoidance of problems.
What's really powerful to me about all of
this is it is completely in our minds.
We can control it.
If we choose to put aside
this concept of destiny and
instead embrace the idea of growth, and
the idea of working through the lows,
we can all have happier and
healthier relationships.
When I thought of couples
who did this well,
I immediately thought of
my husband's grandparents.
Grandma Ada and
Pops have been married for 67 years.
Two years ago we celebrated
their 65th anniversary.
It was so moving to see how they
happy they were to have their kids,
their grandkids, and their great-grandkids
all assembled in one room.
This is a photo of them in
1949 when they got married.
And this is another photo more
recently taken right before the party.
When I called to ask them what
they thought about love and
relationships, I learned
some interesting things.
First, I learned that my husband
had sneakily been talking to Pops
almost since the day we got married and
getting his advice.
I would argue that Jason has been
employing Pops' advice to great effect in
our relationship.
According to Pops, there are three little
words that can make a successful marriage.
And they are yes, my dear.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
in all seriousness, Gramma Ada did give
me some real material to work with.
She said we've shared
some incredible highs,
the birth of our children as one example.
We've also shared some really deep lows,
in particular the health problems they've
experienced recently as
they've gotten older.
At any moment, she said, you have
the choice to stay in a relationship or
to leave it,
particularly when times get tough.
Maybe I'm a little bit higher on
destiny than I'd like to admit, but
I was surprised.
I thought that they were going to
talk about love and the meant to be.
And instead, both of them just
talked about how hard it was.
This wasn't at all what
I was expecting to hear.
Love is a wave with highs and lows.
My wish for all of us sitting in this
room today is that we can put aside this
idea of destiny, that we can stop
thinking about the meant to be and
instead embrace what we have today.
If we embrace the work that
the lows take to get through,
we can all have healthier and
happier friendships, family relationships,
and yes, even romantic
relationships with our loved ones.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]